Trascrizione: Riccardo Sasso
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Ma dico io: a quest'ora della sera,
siete ancora desiderosi e desiderose?
No, perché i desideri
hanno anche dei limiti:
diciamocelo, dopo tutta questa giornata!
Io, per esempio,
un limite ce l'ho - fra i tanti.
Quando mi chiedono
se mi piacciono i dolci,
io tendo a rispondere subito:
no, lascia perdere,
perché proprio i dolci non li desidero!
Ma non è proprio così.
Perché se mi offrite -
anche domani, eh: con calma -
una fetta di torta di ricotta e pere
io non resisto, e ho un moto
di commozione vera.
Ma c'è un perché.
Perché una mattina,
ero appena entrata a scuola in aula,
ho sentito un leggero tocco sulla spalla;
e quando mi sono girata,
ho visto una magnifica torta
di ricotta e pere, appunto.
Subito dietro, lo sguardo brillante
di una mia alunna dodicenne
e la sua voce fiera e decisa, che mi dice:
"Prof, l'assaggi!
Questo era un mio non so".
Era successo il giorno prima,
in quel gruppo di preadolescenti
che stavo osservando da un po'.
E mi sembravano frenati,
già discreti militanti della competizione
ma altrettanto schiacciati
sulle prestazioni, sulle ansie,
sulle aspettative degli adulti.
Io ho deciso di proporre una cosa.
Ho detto loro: "Prendete un foglio,
e scrivete dalle cinque alle dieci cose" -
anzi: in realtà, siccome ero
la prof di matematica, ho detto:
"Scrivete un numero,
compreso fra cinque e dieci,
di cose che siete davvero convinti
di non saper fare.
Quando avete finito, cancellate i "non so"
all'inizio di ogni frase,
e sostituiteli con "posso" o "voglio";
E poi, prendetevi qualche istante
per rileggere le frasi così trasformate,
e magari sentire che effetto vi fa".
Vedete: io avevo l'intenzione
di attivare un movimento
verso qualcosa che intuivo
che quei ragazzi
si stavano precludendo da soli,
e non per sottoscrivere
il vecchio detto "Volere è potere".
Tanto meno per fare del pensiero positivo.
Molto più semplicemente,
volevo provare ad aprire un varco,
proprio una fessura di fiducia,
socchiudere una porta blindata
che io, sentivo,
li stava separando dalla vita.
E soprattutto, che aveva su di sé
una targa gigantesca;
e c'era scritto: "Io non sono capace".
E comunque, quella torta
di ricotta e pere,
quella metamorfosi dal "non so" a "posso",
vi assicuro, era buonissima;
tant'è vero che non resisto
neanche adesso.
Il fatto è che, al momento
della nostra nascita,
sicuramente qualcuno ha detto,
o ha scritto, di noi "è venuta alla luce";
e al momento della nostra morte,
qualcun altro probabilmente dirà,
o scriverà, "si è spenta".
Non so voi, ma a me interessa
quello che c'è nel mezzo.
E in mezzo?
Quando, e come, impariamo
ad accendere la luce?
E soprattutto a mantenerla accesa?
Prima, però, dobbiamo sfatare
un luogo comune.
Anche in questi tempi di pandemie,
i luoghi comuni sono rimasti
drammaticamente affollati.
Il luogo comune per cui noi
saremmo capaci di desiderare
tanto più quanto siamo nati
dal desiderio dei nostri genitori.
Allora, diciamocela tutta
con franchezza, a partire da me:
se così fosse,
la metà di noi non sarebbe in grado
di accendere la candelina del compleanno.
Invece, io sono convinta che,
credo per fortuna, il desiderio si impari.
Se penso a me la rintraccio facilmente,
la mia prima esperienza
cosciente del desiderare.
Avevo otto - nove anni,
e per il mio io di quell'età
una bicicletta era il salvacondotto
verso l'avventura e l'indipendenza.
Era, letteralmente,
lo svincolo a due ruote dall'infanzia.
Ma all'epoca, i miei genitori e nonni
mi posero una condizione ferma,
e molto semplice:
la bici sarebbe arrivata,
ma solo alla fine dell'anno scolastico.
E solo se avessi guadagnato
una delle borse di studio
che metteva a disposizione
l'ente per cui lavorava mio padre.
Ebbene, io tutti quei mesi -
e sono stati davvero tanti,
me li ricordo ancora -
tutti i giorni sono stata
in compagnia di due cose:
dell'attesa, e dell'immaginazione.
Guardate che immaginare
è molto diverso da fantasticare.
Prima ho visto il colore: rosso.
Poi sono arrivati i particolari:
il manubrio cromato, il piccolo fanale,
il sellino, il portapacchi.
Poi mi ci sono vista su,
e ho sentito il suono delle ruote
che stridevano sull'asfalto;
e poi il suono del campanello,
e la pressione dei miei piedi sui pedali,
l'effetto dell'aria sulle guance.
Ma soprattutto, la gioia;
e il senso, prorompente, di libertà.
Questo sentivo, fervido e reale.
E questa sono io, alla fine
della mia prima scuola di desiderio,
e dei suoi ingredienti.
Non so se si vede la mia faccia,
ma ho proprio la faccia
di una che è stata promossa.
E oggi?
È vero che viviamo un tempo
dannatamente scomodo
per tutti, e per tutte;
ma voglio dirlo chiaro
che per le bambine e per i bambini
questo è molto più scomodo,
come tempo da vivere.
E allora, quanto loro fanno l'esperienza,
non solo dell'attesa e dell'immaginazione,
ma anche di altri ingredienti
che sono fondamentali
per imparare a desiderare?
Per esempio del silenzio,
quel silenzio buono
che parla il linguaggio
del dialogo ancestrale
con tutti gli esseri,
viventi e non viventi.
E poi della noia che, vi assicuro,
spaventa tantissimo
soprattutto i genitori;
e che è uno spazio vuoto,
un tempo sospeso,
un'avventura della mente:
è l'ascolto del niente che attira tutto.
Anche della confusione:
da cui, però, arrivano immagini nuove.
Io temo che, troppo spesso,
le bambine e i bambini invece
sentono questo, e imparano questo:
che il silenzio è una cosa
brutta, ostile e spaventosa.
Che ha il sapore del rimprovero,
e della riprovazione.
E che la vita è uno spazio
da riempire di corsa;
e i desideri, esattamente
come gli oggetti,
merci da acquistare,
da consumare con voracità
e, magari, per sentirsi migliori.
E allora io, davanti a queste cose,
provo a farmi una domanda
che per me è la più corretta.
La pongo anche a voi:
allora cosa posso fare io?
Cosa possiamo fare noi?
A parte fare i conti con le nostre paure,
io provo a portarvi in due parole,
che ho raccolto da loro,
da bambini e da adolescenti.
Per esempio, quella volta
che un ragazzino di 11 anni,
parlandomi delle notizie
che portano ogni giorno dal mondo -
storie di ingiustizie, violenze,
guerre, malattie, atrocità,
quelle stesse che noi
prima guardiamo un po' sgomenti,
poi turbati e via via più anestetizzati.
Lui mi ha detto, un giorno:
"Rosi, io davanti a questo
mi sento sconcertato! ".
Cioè, "privato del concerto".
Non ci avevo mai pensato prima
che la parola concerto
è una parola meravigliosa,
perché "concerto" significa
"tendere insieme verso qualcosa".
Quindi quel bambino mi stava dicendo
del suo desiderio di cercare,
tutti insieme, un'armonia comune.
E poi, c'è un'altra parola
che ricorre quasi tutte le volte
che incontrò gli adolescenti:
"Non mi sento considerato dai grandi".
"Considerazione" è la seconda
parola che vi porto,
ed è sorprendente la sapienza
delle parole che usano i bambini,
perché desiderio e considerazione
contengono entrambe le stelle.
E allora quando ci dicono
"Non mi sento considerato",
ci stanno dicendo:
"Aiutaci a sentirci parte
della stessa costellazione di umani".
Questo ci stanno dicendo.
Quindi, quello che possiamo dare loro
è provare a vederli,
è provare ad ascoltarli.
Io, una sintesi efficace l'ho trovata
su una scritta che è comparsa
qualche mese fa a Roma,
sulla scalinata della
"Galleria di Arte Moderna".
Non so se la leggete.
È la citazione di una
straordinaria filosofa, Maria Zambrano,
e dice così:
"Le radici devono avere
fiducia nei fiori".
Allora, quello che io
mi propongo, e ci propongo,
è proprio di fare una scelta radicale:
riprenderci il compito di radici.
Perché le radici non hanno paura del buio:
sono lì e si aggrappano
con forza alla terra.
Non si chiedono mai che cosa c'è su,
e tanto meno se il fiore ce la farà;
semplicemente, lo spingono verso il cielo.
Questo fanno le radici,
e questo possiamo fare noi.
Starete pensando: questa la fa
veramente molto negativa,
perché effettivamente
i bambini e le bambine di oggi
stanno molto meglio
di quelli di cent'anni fa.
È vero, lo confermo:
ed è anche vero
che abbiamo imparato, piano piano,
almeno a nominare
alcuni bisogni dei bambini.
Almeno sappiamo che esistono,
e sappiamo che i bisogni
sono una dimensione essenziale
della nostra esistenza.
Il bisogno, però,
non ha un verbo corrispondente.
Ha una piccola famiglia;
per esempio, ha come parenti stretti
l'urgenza e la necessità.
Il bisogno vive nel presente,
improrogabilmente.
Il desiderio ce l'ha eccome, un verbo.
Significa che contiene già
l'idea del movimento,
e poi a me piace
perché ha una famiglia numerosa.
Ha come fratelli il coraggio e il tempo;
e ha come sorelle
delle tipe molto interessanti:
l'immaginazione, che vi ho già presentato;
la fiducia;
e soprattutto una, piccola
ed essenziale: la pazienza.
E la casa del desiderio
è la casa dei bambini e delle bambine,
e la casa del loro diritto
è il futuro.
Vero, sarete ancora pensando.
Tante cose stiamo provando
a farle, per i bambini.
Per esempio, nel mondo
che io conosco meglio,
che è il mondo della scuola,
da almeno 15 anni abbiamo,
meritoriamente, dato attenzione
ad alcuni bisogni di bambine e bambini.
E li abbiamo, anche, raggruppati
all'interno di una grande sigla,
che è "BES": i Bisogni Educativi Speciali.
È importantissimo che l'abbiamo fatto.
Tuttavia, mi viene qualche dubbio
perché ho la sensazione
che rischiamo di confondere,
qualche volta, i bisogni
con l'identità dei singoli bambini.
Lo dico perché, spesso,
mi capita di ascoltare
come gli insegnanti raccontano -
sapete che il modo in cui
ci rappresentiamo l'esperienza
è particolarmente interessante -
Ascolto gli insegnanti che raccontano
del loro anno passato,
per esempio, così:
"Quest'anno è stato
veramente molto faticoso:
avevo una classe con tre BES
e quattro DSA".
Invece che dire:
una classe con tre bambini
con bisogni educativi speciali
e quattro bambini con disturbi
specifici dell'apprendimento.
E a questo proposito,
io credo sia necessario
che continuiamo ad interrogarci
su come aiutare i bambini
con bisogni educativi speciali
e disturbi specifici dell'apprendimento,
aiutarli a crescere e dare loro
le stesse opportunità di tutti.
Ma se nello stesso tempo,
contemporaneamente,
cominciassimo a farci delle domande
anche sui disturbi
specifici dell'insegnamento?
E sui disturbi specifici dell'educazione?
Se cominciassimo - o provassimo, almeno -
ad allargare lo sguardo
dai BES, quindi da
"sono soggetti con i bisogni",
ai DES, ai "Desideri educativi speciali",
io sento che così avremo
qualche possibilità in più
di intercettare quelle domande
che premono dietro gli occhi
dei bambini di ogni tempo,
anche di questo.
Perché i bambini e le bambine
sono esperti in interrogativi cosmici;
sono le stesse domande che,
a un certo punto della vita,
molti di noi smettono di farsi.
Sono delle domande
che io stasera vi consegno:
se volete le mettete in tasca,
le mettete in borsa
e quando vi va, tiratele fuori.
Non per rispondere,
ma semplicemente per fargli prendere aria.
Perché mai come ora
c'è bisogno di queste domande,
le domande di sempre dei bambini:
"Io chi sono, e perché sono qui"?
Mi sento ancora molto vicina a loro,
mentre si fanno queste domande.
E per questo vi lascio con le parole
che, per provare a rispondere
ha usato Eduardo Galeano,
che penso poco fa
abbia citato anche Tonio.
Eduardo Galeano prova a rispondere,
nella sua "Finestra sul volto",
e il volto è quanto di più umano ci resti.
Prova a dirci, secondo lui,
chi siamo e perché siamo qua.
E lo fa così:
"Una macchina stupida?
Una lettera che ignora il suo mittente,
e ha sbagliato destinazione?
O una pallottola perduta,
che un dio ha sparato per errore?
Noi veniamo da un uovo più piccolo
della testa di uno spillo,
e viviamo su un pietra
che gira intorno ad una stella nana,
e che contro questa stella,
prima o poi, si scontrerà.
Tuttavia siamo stati fatti di luce,
oltre che di carbonio, di ossigeno,
di merda e di altre cose.
Ma in fin dei conti, siamo qui
da quando la bellezza dell'universo
ha avuto bisogno
di essere vista da qualcuno.
Grazie.
(Applausi)